Speaker 1: All right. Third, looking at 2022
elections, we go to Doug Mastriano. Now, the
context here is that Doug Mastriano is one of the
most unhinged and dangerous top level Republican
candidates this election cycle. Doug Mastriano
wants the voters of Pennsylvania to make him
their governor. We have an alternative whose just
completely uncontroversial and normal. His name is
Josh SHAPIRO. He's the Democrat. And if you vote
in Pennsylvania, I suggest that you support Josh
SHAPIRO. Here is Doug Mastriano bravely taking
the position at an event over the weekend that
if he becomes. The governor of Pennsylvania.
He will ban pole dancing in public schools
and he will ban pornography in public schools.
Are there those things in public school? Well,
it doesn't really seem like it, but he's going
to ban them very strongly. Check this out. And
by the way, look at the crowd reaction.
Speaker 6: On day one. The sexualization,
our kids, pole dancing and all this other crap
is going on will be forbidden in our schools.
Speaker 1: Ban it.
Speaker 6:
On day one, all the graphic,
pornographic, pornographic.
Speaker 1: The pornographic, etc..
Speaker 6: In elementary schools will
be will be pulled out.
Speaker 1:
They're going to pull it out.
Speaker 6:
On day one and done. Critical
race theory is out the window.
Speaker 1: And if they don't know what it is,
but they sure know how to throw it out of a
window. What image does Doug Mastriano have
of what happens in schools like? Is there a
lot of pole dancing in Pennsylvania elementary
schools? It's sort of like I will ban heroin at
lunchtime in our public schools. Oh, wow.
So that sounds serious. Is there heroin
being distributed at lunchtime? No, no. But I'm
going to ban it right away. While you're at it,
ban the virus as well and just take care of that
problem. Fortunately, the polling in Pennsylvania
looks pretty okay right now for Josh SHAPIRO. On
average, SHAPIRO is leading this radical, unhinged
Republican by ten. SHAPIRO Plus 10.2 doesn't mean
we stay home, doesn't mean we assume we have it in
the bag. But it is looking like if everybody who
says they're going to vote votes, Doug Mastriano
will be sent back to wherever he came from. And
he can work on issues like pornography and pole
dancing in school. Three of the races we will
talk about many more this week. We'll take a
quick break. Let me know on Twitter at the Pacman,
what race are you paying the most attention to?